can I make it in America it's a question
I got from a reader zhu yin i hope i
pronounced that properly rodents ad
revenue read your website a few seconds
ago i wanted to create a toy for kids
I'm an international student I want to
know can I have success as an
entrepreneur in America and part 2 how
can I get my toy created how to get to a
toy company I'm awaiting your response
so a great question here's the thing if
you believe you can make it in America
then you can make it in America the
biggest thing holding you back is your
limiting personal beliefs and this is
for everybody the biggest problem in
your business right now is not your
branding it's not your marketing is not
raising capital it's not your employees
it's your own limiting personal beliefs
every time I've had an interview where
somebody says what keeps you up at night
really if I look deep it's my own
limiting personal beliefs and every time
I've seen a major growth forward with my
business is because I changed my story I
changed my beliefs and my business took
off as a result so whatever you're
telling yourself there's something there
there's some things some little voice
that's holding you back from being the
entrepreneur forming the person that you
are meant to be that you could be if you
stop holding yourself back if you took
off the chains and let yourself run
loose so yes you can have success in
America even if you're an international
student that's not a reason that's not
an excuse it's never about your
background your resources and it's
always about your resourcefulness and
your willingness to do it if you believe
you can then you can use going to be
hard it's give me a lot of work but you
can't for the second part about selling
into a toy company the fastest way to
learn something the FAFSA would
accomplish any goal it's the model
success find somebody who's already done
what you're trying to do and put their
strategies to work for you so if
never created a toy before if you've
never had any success in this business I
would start by trying to model someone
who has research the stories of famous
entrepreneurs look at toy companies who
you look up to and respect and look at
how they got started look at what steps
they did to launch their company in
there there's so many clues for your
success and supplies to any entrepreneur
whatever business you're in stop trying
to solve every single problem yourself
people have already solved it before if
you're trying to find your first
customer every single business in
existence had that problem they solved
it learn from them when I was struggling
with my business making three hundred
dollars a month unsure of what to do
thinking of closing down feeling like a
total failure feeling ashamed and
embarrassed and not not willing to talk
to to my friends but what was going on
because I was so down on myself thinking
I should be so far ahead than making
three hundred dollars a month what saved
me what saved my business was modeling
the success of another software company
Microsoft and I looked at how they got
started I looked at how they sold and
with them was through partnerships and I
looked at exactly what Bill Gates did
and I modeled it and I applied it to my
business and I made it work and then I
modeled more from Microsoft I modeled
how they did their advertising I modeled
how they did their press releases
instead of me trying to figure out
everything by myself I took what was
working for somebody else and applied it
to my business so whatever problem
you're facing go and do the same thing I
know it's hard and it's scary venturing
out into something new and it's easy to
get down and say I'm never going to make
it because because i'm a student i'm
never going to make it because I'm a
foreigner I'm never going to make it
because I've never built the toy company
before and that's what everybody's going
to tell you by the way right even with
the best of intentions your friends your
family oh that's a great idea but you're
never going to make it because you don't
have the resources or you
ever done this before or XYZ all the all
the answers excuses in the world you
have to overcome those you have to
believe in yourself you have to believe
that everything is possible it's got to
come from from your heart that you
really have an intense desire to build
this business because there's a great
cause is a great problem that you're
trying to solve and you could leave your
mark and have an impact on the world and
you're not going to give up until you do
it if that's your mind said everything
is possible believe thank you everybody
for watching you like this video please
give it a thumbs up below and please
leave a comment underneath I really
appreciate those when they come in even
feature saying thanks to the video if
you have a question too would be happy
to answer it leave it in the comments
section below and I'll do a video
response thank you guys I'll see you
soon